i want to talk about an inflamed liver the
problem with people that have inflammation
in the liver is many times they don't know they
have inflammation in the liver and it progresses
uh developing scar tissue and then fibrosis and
then cirrhosis and so the good news about the
liver is that it's robust and it is one of the
only organs that can completely regenerate but
you also have to realize that there are so many
people out there that have inflammation in the
liver and they don't have a clue and it's building
up over time and a lot of symptoms don't occur
until later in life but one of the big symptoms is
that you're just a little lethargic a little tired
and you don't know that's connected to inflamed
liver i had an inflamed liver for many years and
i didn't really know it in fact i had a lot of the
symptoms in my right shoulder right up to my neck
and i had no idea that was my liver and if someone
would have educated me on that a long time ago
i would have been able to do something about it
and now my weakness is my liver and so if you
have inflammation in your liver or scar tissue
or even a fatty liver that can also give you a
lot of additional problems like arthritis and
thyroid function and a lot of digestive issues
and weakness within the gallbladder because the
liver makes bile and if you don't have the full
liver capacity you're not going to have the bile
to help you digest all the fat soluble vitamins
and so the first thing you need to know is
what are the most common things that can cause
inflammation in your liver number one sugar number
two refined carbohydrates number three alcohol
number four vegetable oils which is in most
of your foods if you go to the grocery store
soy oil corn oil canola cotton seed
very very damaging on the liver
also too much snacking can raise insulin and
create a lot of inflammation in your liver
as well and also there are people that
have a lot of autoimmune diseases okay
so their own immune system is attacking their
own organs and in autoimmune conditions people
nearly always have an inflamed liver and so if
you're watching and you have an autoimmune disease
this video is for you the the problem with
inflammation in general is that cancer tends to
travel to areas of inflammation so your goal
should be to eliminate as much inflammation
as possible just to prevent any cancer
from traveling if you happen to get cancer
with inflammation of liver over time you
slowly lose liver function but it's very
very slow and you might not even be aware that
it's occurring until it's pretty well invaded
uh most of the liver function the interesting
thing about the liver is you don't need much of
it to function normally it's a robust organ it can
take a beating and it can completely regenerate
if you don't let it get too far cruciferous
vegetables are probably one of the best
things you can consume to help support the
liver alright let's talk about the things
that you should be doing if you have an inflamed
liver milk thistle very important 500 milligrams
per day okay milk thistle it's called
hepatoprotective it protects the liver cells
next thing is vitamin d vitamin d is the best
natural anti-inflammatory it has virtually no
side effects and i would take vitamin d at levels
between 10,000 to 20,000 or even more per day
those are IUs international units and more if you
have a lot of information or an autoimmune disease
the next thing i would highly recommend and
this is very very important is fasting at
least 18 hours of no food you can drink water
but no food in that 18 hours okay so you'd have
six hour eating window and 18 hours of fasting
that's going to give you a tremendous amount of
what's called autophagy which is going to help
to repair liver function it's going to help to
take these damaged proteins in the liver the scar
tissue and help to recycle that into new liver
tissue very very very important the other remedy
i'm going to recommend is called tudca tudca is my
secret remedy to a lot of different conditions
especially with inflammation in your liver
basically tudca is bare bile okay it's made
synthetically but even though it's synthetic it
seems to be something that's uh very beneficial
and i've never seen any negative effects from
taking tutta i would take two in the morning
on an empty stomach and two in the afternoon
on an empty stomach and it's going to increase
the flow of bile it's going to create a nice
anti-inflammatory effect very cool stuff and
then tocatrinals this is a type of vitamin e
one of the best most powerful types of
vitamin e like 50 times stronger than
tocopherols take 300 milligrams per day with
a meal and the tocotrienols the vitamin e is
going to go in there and really clean up
the free radicals for you very powerful as
an anti-inflammatory very good also for any
type of heart problems and coronary artery
problems and then the last thing is selenium at
200 micrograms not milligrams micrograms selenium
is a very good antioxidant for the liver it's
also good to help decrease the risk for cancer
it's also good for the thyroid in converting t4
to t3 but overall we have milk thistle vitamin d
fasting tut cut tocatrino selenium and cruciferous
vegetables are all important for an inflamed liver
and also preventing the scarring of the liver hey
before you go if you're benefiting from any of my
content i would love to hear about your success
story please share it in the link down below